so i've got three lines in r2 and i want
to find their intersection so the first
one is two x
minus y
is equal to two the second one is x
plus two y
is equal to one and the third one is x
plus y
is equal to four so let's first let's
just graph these just have a visual
representation of what we're trying to
do so i like writing my lines and y
equals mx plus b form so this top line
becomes what minus y is equal to minus
2x
minus 2x plus 2. i just subtracted 2x
from both sides or we could write that y
is equal to 2x minus two that's that
first line here the second line under in
green we could write this as two y is
equal to minus x plus one or we could
write that y
is equal to
minus one-half x
plus one-half i just divided both sides
by two
and then this last line right here
we could write this as y is equal to
minus x plus four i could go straight
here y is equal to minus x
plus 4.
now let me graph these
let me graph these let me draw an axis
that is my y-axis i can call it my
y-axis since we're actually dealing with
x and y's now and let's say that this is
my do a slightly lighter well i'll do
i'll do it in this gray as well
and say that is my x-axis
just like that and this first guy is
going to be 2x minus 2 so it's
y-intercept is going to be at minus 2.
it's going to have a slope of 2. so it's
going to be a pretty steep line just
like that
so that's that first line just like that
2x minus 2. the next line is one-half
minus one-half plus one-half
so if we go plus one-half that's right
there and then the slope is minus
one-half so
for every two we go over we go down one
so it's going to be like that it's
actually going to be orthogonal right
because it's the negative inverse of
this guy
so it's going to look something
it's going to look something like that
let me
draw it like that
just like that and then this guy is
minus x plus 4.
so we go this is 1
2 3 4 and you go minus x so for every
one you go over you go down one so this
other line is going to look something
like this
this other line this last line is going
to look something like that just like
that now i said at the beginning of this
video that i want to find the
intersection of these three lines but
notice there is no intersection of these
three lines they all intersect the other
two but they don't all intersect each
other in one point we can kind of call
the system as being over determined
we've over constrained it there is no
intersection of all three of these
points so if i were to actually try to
solve the system i would find no
solution and to say that this has no
solution is equivalent to saying that
this matrix has no or this equation has
no solution let me write this i'm just
going to rewrite the system like this
this is equivalent
to
the matrix let me make sure i get this
right the matrix times
the vector
x y
is equal to
is equal to 2
1 and 4.
and so this first equation is 2 times x
minus 1 times y so it's 2
and minus 1. 2 times x minus 1 times y
is equal to 2. that's that first
equation over there the second equation
actually i could even well i won't color
code it that'll take forever that's 1
times x plus 2 times y is equal to 1 and
then we have x plus y is equal to 4.
this system and this equation this
system right here these are equivalent
now this isn't going to have any
solution you could try to find a
solution to this you could put create an
augmented matrix put in reduced row
echelon form but there is no
intersection to these three things so
you're not going to find a solution to
a
times some vector we could call this
some vector x is equal to b or another
way to say it is that b is not in the
column space of this matrix right here
now we learned in the last video that
sure we can't find a solution to ax
equal to b
ax equals b
has no solution
no solution
we see it graphically here these lines
don't intersect with each other and you
could prove it for yourself
algebraically by trying to find a
solution here you'll end up with a zero
equals one but we can almost get there
by finding a least square solution and
we find a least square solution if we
multiply both sides by a transpose we
know that a transpose times a times our
least squares solution
is going to be equal to a
transposed times b
so at least we can find the closest fit
for our solution so let's find the
vector x that is our least square
solution so what is a transposed times a
so a transpose looks like this
it'll have 2 minus 1
1 2
1 1 that is a transpose and then of
course a
is just this thing 2 minus 1 1 2
1 1.
so a transpose a is going to be equal to
we have a 2 by 3 times a 3 by two matrix
so it's going to be a two by two matrix
so what do we get we get two times two
which is four
plus one times one plus one times one so
it's four plus one plus one so that's
equal to
six
and then we have two times minus one
which is minus two plus one times two
so those cancel out you have minus two
plus two that's zero plus one times one
so that's just going to be one
and then we get minus
one times two which is minus two plus
two times one which is two so the minus
two plus two is zero plus one times one
so we get a one
and then finally we get minus one times
minus one which is positive one plus two
times two which is four so we're in out
five plus one times one so this is going
to be six so this is a
transpose a
now what is
a transpose times b
a transpose
is 2 1 1
-1 2 1
and then b is just
the three by one vector the vector
that's a member of r three
two one four
so what is this going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to see we have
a this is we get this is going to this
is three
this is a sorry this is a 2 by 3 times 8
3 by 1 we're going to get a 2 by 1
vector
and get 2 by 1 vector here so 2 times 2
is four
plus one times one so that's plus one so
that's five plus let me actually write
it down i'm going to make a cursor take
two times two which is four
plus one times one which is one plus one
times four which is four and then here
you have minus one times two which is
minus two two times one which is two
plus one times four which is four
so a transpose times b
is equal to
and this is going to be 4.
so we can rewrite this guy right here as
the matrix
as the matrix a transpose a which is
just 6
1 6
times my least squares solution so this
is actually going to be in the column
space
of a
is equal to a transpose times b
which is just
the vector
9 4.
and this will be a little bit more
straightforward to find a solution for
in fact there will be a solution we've
proved it in the last video so to find a
solution let's create our little
augmented matrix 6 1 augment it with a 9
you put the 4 there and you get a 1 and
a 6
just like that
let's put the left hand side in reduced
row echelon form actually first i'm
going to swap
i am going to swap these two rows that's
my first row operation that i choose to
do just because i like to have that one
there it's a nice pivot entry so then i
get it goes to
one six
four and six one nine
and then
let me replace my second row with the
second row minus six times the first row
so i'm going to keep my first row the
same
so i have one
six
and
four
and then my second row i'm gonna replace
my second row with the second row minus
six times the first row so six minus six
is zero
one
minus six times six that's one minus 36
so that's minus 35
and then 9 minus 6 times 4 is 9 minus 24
this one always gets me in trouble so 9
minus 24 that's the negative of 24
minus 9 so that is
minus 15
minus 15. let me make sure i didn't make
a careless mistake 1 minus 36 is minus
9 minus 24
9 minus 24 is minus 15. so that's what i
get right there
and then
let me go to the right
now so let me
let me divide this row right here let me
divide it by minus
so i'm going to keep my first draw the
same 1 6
and 4 and then this guy right here i'm
going to divide by minus 35 so i'm going
to get 0 1 and then minus 15
over minus 35 that's 15 over 35
or
that's 3 over 7 so that is equal to 3 7.
and then if i really want to well let me
just put this in complete reduced row
echelon form that'll be nice let me
replace let me keep my second row the
same so my second row is 0
and 3 7
and then
my first row i'm going to replace it
with my
first row minus 6 times my second row so
one minus six times zero is one
six minus six times one is zero and then
we have four minus six times three
sevenths
so four is 28 sevenths let me write it
up here so we have 4 which is 28 7
minus 6 times 3 7 so minus
18 7 right that's 6 times 3 7
so this is going to be equal to
10 7.
is going to be equal to ten-sevenths
ten-sevenths and just like that i've
solved this new equation so you could
say that
let me write it this way
we could write that x-star
this is going to the first entry of x
star which we could call x is going to
be 10 sevenths let me write this
x star
the solution is going to be
ten
sevenths
and three sevenths so i'm saying that if
you take x is equal to 10 7 and y is
equal to 3 7 you're going to get as
close to a solution as possible so let's
see what that looks like visually what
is 10 7 so let me write this down x star
is equal to
10 sevenths
and three sevenths
or
we're saying the closest our least
square solution is x is equal to 10
sevens so x is a little over one x is a
little over one
and then y is going to be three sevens a
little less than one half so our least
square solution is going to be this one
right there and so this when you put
this this value for x when you put
when you put
x is equal to
10 7
and y
y is equal to three sevenths you're
going to minimize the collective squares
of the distances between all of these
guys and i'm i drew this a little bit
too small to show that but let's
actually figure out what our least what
our minimized difference is what our
minimized distance is so remember the
whole point of this the whole point of
this is to minimize the distance between
a x
star
is to minimize the distance between a
x-star and b
or between
b and a x star now what was a x star
equal to a x star
a x star was equal to
a x star was equal to 9 4.
so this right here
sorry ax star that's not equal to 9 4.
that's a transpose ax star is equal to 9
4. ax star is our original matrix a
which is this one right here so 2
let me write it down here
i know it's off the page right now so
our original matrix a was 2
minus 1 1 2
1 1. that was our original matrix a
right there and then our x star
we were able to determine is 10 sevenths
and three sevenths
so a x star is going to be this product
so what is it equal to
it is equal to it's going to be a three
by one matrix
so we get two times ten sevenths which
is twenty
sevenths
minus one times three seven so minus
three
sevenths and then we get let me see yep
that's 20 right minus three cents and we
have ten sevenths
and we have ten sevens minus two times
three seven so minus six sevenths
or plus sorry this is a plus
right 2 times 10 7 is 27 minus 1 times 3
7. then we have 1 times 10 7 plus 2
times 3 7 and then we have 10 7 plus 3 7
10 7 plus 3 7. so a x so this is a and x
star our least squares approximation for
x is equal to
is equal to what is this this is 17
sevenths this is 16 7 and this is 13
sevenths
and we are minimum we want to find out
what this minimum distance is so let's
see so this is going to be
this thing so 17
16 sevenths and thirteen sevenths
minus our original b now our original b
was
two
one
and four
so i'm claiming that my solution that
we've just found this minimizes this
distance because this is the or this is
the projection of b onto the column
space of a we saw that before so our b
we see all the way up here is 2 1 4 2 1
4 just like that
so if we take the length of this let me
switch colors
this is equal to the length
let me write all of this in sevenths two
i'll just do it in my head
i don't want to waste too much time
so this is 17 7 minus 14 sevens right 2
is 14 7. so this is going to be 3 7 and
we have 16 7
minus 7 7 so that's 9
7 and then we have 13 7
minus 28 7 so that is minus 15 over 7.
so this is the vector that separates the
b that was not in my column space of a
from my best the projection of b and if
we find its length
its length is going to be equal to
well it's going to be equal to let's
let's find the square of its length
first the square of its length is going
to be 3 7 squared so that is 9 49
9 49
plus
9 7 squared which is 81 49
50 minus 15 7 squared so that's what's
15 squared 15 squared is 225 i think let
me make sure
i'm prone to careless mistakes 5 times 5
is
25 1 times 5
this is 75 and then i have a 150 yep 225
so plus
over 49. which is equal to so 9
9 plus 81 is 90 and then so 225 plus 90
we get a 5 was it 3
right so this is equal to 3
15 over 49 or if we actually wanted the
difference right that's going to be the
square root of this
that's going to be equal to so if we
take just the regular distance that's
equal to the square root of that so it's
equal to the square root of 3 15
over
over 7. and square root of 315 it looks
like that is simplifiable does 9 go into
it looks like 9 goes into it maybe 35
times so it would be what 3 square roots
of 35
over 7. so that is just to measure this
you're not going to find and let me put
it this way you're not going to be able
to find any member of r2 any values of x
and y that's going to give you a smaller
value than this when you find the
distance between its solution and the
solution you were trying to get to
so this based on our least square
solution is the best
estimate you're going to get x is equal
to 10 7
y is equal to
3 7. so a little bit a little bit right
just just like that anyway hopefully you
found that useful and you're starting to
appreciate that the least square
solution is pretty useful